the easiest tax strategies that you can
use if you're a small business owner
called the augusta rule if you have your
house you can rent your house to your
business for employee meetings for
member events so if you have clients or
customers who are flying into town or
you want to hold an event or a small
mastermind or a workshop at your home
you can lease it to your business the
industrial states that we can lease our
home to our business for up to 14 days
and so whatever my day rate is that
would be fair market i can multiply that
by 14 and i can write myself a check for
that provided i've used my home for that
period of time for perspective if you're
even making a hundred thousand dollars a
year and you can lease your home to
yourself at a fair market rate of let's
say 500 a day or maybe a thousand
dollars a day that's 14 000 that you can
write yourself as a tax-free check and
take a deduction off of your income from
the business easy strategy and if you
have a cpa which hopefully you do just
tell them it's the guest role and what
you plan to do with it and they should
be able to walk you through it from